mieux comprendre la situation européenne
ainsi que les enjeux du prochain scrutin
pour cette réunion à voisins le
bretonneux le public était au rendez
vous parmi les intervenants l'ancien
député européen philippe herzog
l'union européenne n'arrive pas à
avancer parce que chaque état quand dans
sa souveraineté nationale
donc on partage trop peu on devrait
partager beaucoup plus pourrait servir
qu'on peut appeler des biens communs
européens comme l'éducation l'emploi
l'industrie
toutes ces questions là devraient faire
l'objet maintenant de coupe de politique
commune aux côtés de l'ancien conseiller
spécial de michel barnier jean arthuis
l'ex ministre de l'économie a quant à
lui évoqué les enjeux du prochain
scrutin et son importance il est urgent
que l'europe parle enfin
vos citoyens qu'elle dise à quel point
c'est elle qui peut préparer notre
avenir et qui peut nous protéger si
cette europe là qu'il faut construire
que ce soit en matière de changement
climatique de migration ou encore de je
dirais de de régulation des grands
géants du numérique est bien l'europe à
des solutions à nous apporter encore
faut-il pouvoir se saisir de ces
solutions
lors des dernières élections en 2014
seul 42,61 % des citoyens de l'union
européenne s'étaient déplacés aux urnes